Europe's economic map is being redrawn.
For 70 years, the heart of Europe's
economy beat in Berlin. Now, that heart
is being surgically removed and
transplanted 300 miles to the east. In
2023, while German industrial production
fell by up to 2%, Poland absorbed a
flood of German manufacturing, pushing
its economy toward the $1 trillion mark.
Defying Brussels and rejecting Western
European rules, Poland is pulling off
one of the most dramatic industrial
shifts in modern history. This isn't a
catch-up story. It's a takeover. In
September 2025, Poland hit a milestone
once reserved for the world's economic
giants. Its [music] GDP had surpassed $1
trillion, putting it in the same league
as the United States, Germany, France,
the United Kingdom, China, and Japan. At
first glance, Poland doesn't seem to fit
in that list. It looks like an outlier,
an anomaly. This is, after all, the same
nation that sat behind the Iron Curtain
just a few decades ago. A country that
certainly wasn't known as an economic
powerhouse when it entered the European
Union in 2004. It was more associated
with cheap labor rather than any sort of
domestic industrial might. Yet, here it
is, with a trillion-dollar economy and
ever-increasing influence not just in
Europe, but on the global stage. And at
the very same time Poland is rising, its
neighbor Germany is suffering a dramatic
decline. The contrast between the two
countries is striking. For decades,
Germany was Europe's undisputed
industrial powerhouse. It dominated
manufacturing and built a global
reputation for producing everything from
luxury automobiles to advanced
industrial machinery. Germany wasn't
just Europe's largest economy, it was
the motor that kept the entire European
project running. But in 2023, that motor
started to sputter. Industrial
production rates fell by approximately 1
and 1/2 to 2%. Then came the so-called
Mittelstand exodus. One of the reasons
why Germany has been so successful over
the years is its vast network of
successful small-to-medium-sized
businesses, collectively known as the
Mittelstand. They may not get the
attention of bigger brands and Fortune
500 firms, but these companies are often
world leaders in their specific niche
markets. But together, they make up a
massive part of Germany's economic
strength. Between 2023 and 2024,
however, a staggering 32% of the
country's Mittelstand manufacturers
reported plans to move production out of
Germany. The Rhine-Ruhr Valley, the
forge of Germany's economic foundations,
is being hollowed out one company at a
time. And they're not moving to China or
the US. They're not going far at all, in
fact, just over the eastern border into
Poland. German appliance giant Miele has
moved its washing machine production out
of Germany to a facility in Zawiercie,
Poland. Heating company Viessmann poured
200 million euros into a new heat pump
production plant in Legnica, while
winding down its operations in
long-standing German hubs. These aren't
one-off occurrences. They are part of a
much bigger trend. The wealth that
funded the post-war European project is
drifting eastward, and it didn't happen
overnight. This is the culmination of a
30-year master plan that started from
absolute zero. The dawn of the 1990s
brought about the end of one massive
chapter in Polish history and the start
of something completely new. Back then,
the country had almost nothing. Its very
survival hung in the balance. The
collapse of communism delivered
widespread chaos. Factories closed, jobs
were lost, and entire industries
vanished overnight. Poland's new
leadership was left to pick up the
pieces and make sense of the mess. A lot
of countries would have struggled to get
through it, but Poland had a plan. One
that had the potential to either ruin
the country completely or put it on the
path to a far better and brighter
future. The Balcerowicz Plan. Known as
shock therapy, it was a high-stakes
survival plan built around rapid,
sweeping economic reforms. In the span
of a single day, price controls were
lifted, subsidies [music] to state
industries were cut, the currency was
devalued and Poland opened itself up to
international trade. It was an economic
shockwave that tore down the old system
and forced a new one into place. Its
impact was immediate and severe.
Unemployment, which hadn't really even
existed as a concept under communism,
skyrocketed. Millions of people found
themselves without jobs and living
standards plummeted. The state safety
net was falling apart. National income
plunged by 22%. Industrial production
dropped by 25% inflation [music]
soared. But beyond the pain and the
struggle, an economic revolution was
taking place.
>> [music]
>> Since the state had stopped bailing out
businesses that weren't working, old
monopolies died out. In their place
emerged a new private sector with the
potential to rival any in Europe. Lean,
hungry, and with everything to prove,
new businesses rose out of the ashes.
Since they were operating in strict
constraints, Polish entrepreneurs
designed their companies to be
resilient, cost-effective, and flexible.
It set them up for success, not just in
the short term, but for generations to
come. Once the dust had started to
settle, Poland had laid the foundations
for decades of economic expansion, and
time would prove that the Balcerowicz
plan was the right one after all. In
1990, Poland's nominal GDP stood at $65
billion.
Now, it's over $1 trillion.
It's grown more than 15 times larger
under four decades. Most other European
nations can't match that, and shock
therapy didn't just stabilize the
currency and revive the economy, it
created a new generation of workers and
entrepreneurs with a desire to succeed.
For the first time in decades, hard
work, innovation, and risk-taking were
rewarded. All they needed was the
infrastructure, and they found someone
else to pay for it. Poland had put the
pieces in place for long-term success,
but it still needed to link them
together, and it needed roads, rail,
logistic networks, and other
infrastructure. All of that costs money.
Poland didn't want to foot the bill by
itself, so it got more than a little
help from its wealthy Western neighbors.
In 2004, it entered the EU. At the time,
this was widely seen as a generous
[music]
gesture from the West. Wealthier nations
like France, Germany, and the United
Kingdom [music] were extending a helping
hand to the struggling countries of
Eastern Europe. Warsaw, however, saw the
situation through a different lens. It
was a momentous occasion, a sign of
Europe growing stronger and neighboring
nations wanting to help and support one
another. But, it was also a golden
opportunity. An opportunity to execute
the biggest wealth transfer in the
history of the European continent. Over
two decades, Poland [music] absorbed an
astonishing 161.6
billion euros from the EU budget. That's
enough to build more than 100 copies of
the world's tallest building, the Burj
Khalifa. The scale was staggering.
[music]
Tens of billions of dollars were
flooding into Poland every year. But,
getting the money was just part one of
the plan. Poland had to spend it
correctly. Other EU member states had
mismanaged their EU funds and continued
to do so. Poland had no intention of
making the same mistakes. It weaponized
the war chest that it had been given,
[music] directing massive portions into
all important agricultural and
infrastructure developments. In the
following years, Poland constructed a
web of highways, roads, and high-speed
rail corridors that completely rewrote
the logistical maps of Central Europe.
In 2004, the country had just 450 miles
of highways and expressways. By 2024, it
had over 3,100 miles. The roads and rail
lines weren't laid out randomly. Every
[music] inch was carefully calculated
and optimized for efficiency. Bit by
bit, Poland built an enormous
geopolitical trap that the Western world
never saw coming. As the country's
infrastructure [music] improved,
multinational corporations faced a new
choice. They could stay in Western
Europe and deal with rising costs and
strained transport networks, or they
could nearshore their operations to
Poland and take advantage of the lower
costs, EU-funded infrastructure, and a
rapidly expanding workforce. The EU's
Western leaders didn't even see the
impending crisis unfolding in front of
them. They thought that by funding
Poland's development, they were creating
a reliable and even submissive economic
partner. They expected nothing but
political obedience in exchange for
those tens of billions of euros. Warsaw,
meanwhile, was using the West's cash to
rip away its industrial dominance. And
once the infrastructure was in place,
Warsaw was ready to reinforce it with
something that would cement its status,
not [music] as a bit player on the
European stage, but a headline act. In
February 2022, another seismic shift
struck the European continent. Poland
was once again ready to make the most of
the change. Russian tanks and troops
crossed the border into Ukraine,
signaling the start of a years-long war.
The effects would ripple far beyond the
battlefield, impacting politics and
economies around the globe. For decades,
countries like Germany treated defense
as a low priority. Military budgets were
scaled back, while budgets were plowed
into social welfare projects. Warsaw,
however, went the opposite way. It
funneled large amounts of its national
budget into defense. By 2024, its
military spending had surged to a
historic 4.12% of its GDP. That's the
highest percentage in the entire NATO
alliance. Proportionally speaking, it is
double that of Germany and France. It's
even higher than the biggest military
superpower of them all, the United
States, [music] which was around 3.4% of
GDP at the time. Once again, Poland
wasn't just throwing that money around
or spending at random. It was investing
in some of the finest military hardware
on the planet. South Korean K2 Black
Panther main battle tanks, hundreds of
K9 Thunder self-propelled howitzers, and
dozens of FA-50 fighter jets. By the
time Poland's purchases are finished in
2030, the country will have more main
battle tanks than the UK, Germany,
France, and Italy combined. It's pulling
off the most aggressive military
build-up since the Cold War. But that's
not all. Poland isn't just buying tanks
and shipping them in. It has signed
offset deals with South Korea to secure
the technology and the know-how to build
the tanks on its own soil. Today,
hundreds of tanks and howitzers are
rolling off production lines inside of
Poland. And with the war in Ukraine, the
country has also become a vital
logistics hub for US and NATO forces.
Since 2022, countless tons of weapons,
ammunition, and supplies have flowed
through Poland, and the country has
benefited from a massive geopolitical
shield by making itself a reliable
transit corridor while building one of
the continent's strongest armies. Poland
gained importance. The US, the UK,
France, Germany, and other Western
powers can't afford for this country to
fail, so they'll do whatever it takes to
defend and protect it. And with
America's military backing secured,
Poland gained the ultimate leverage to
force the EU's hand. For years, there
was a narrative among Western media
regarding Poland's place on the European
stage. It was seen as a pariah state, a
problem child. Some of Warsaw's more
outspoken leaders were regularly
condemned in the European Parliament.
Brussels often invoked various articles
and EU rights to punish and penalize
Poland. The country was repeatedly fined
and threatened.
>> [music]
>> For a time, it looked like Warsaw would
have to eventually bend the knee and tow
the line, but the war changed
everything. The country was vital for
Europe's survival, so it became harder
for Brussels to threaten or intimidate.
While Western leaders continued to argue
over abstract articles and the rule of
law, Warsaw was focused on what
mattered, using its newfound status as
the Ukraine logistics hub to its
advantage. The turning point came in
early 2024. For months, the European
Commission had kept 137 billion euros
worth of funds that were intended for
Poland on ice. It was a game-changing
amount of cash, completely frozen and
used as a financial chokehold to pile
pressure onto the country's leaders. But
Warsaw didn't blink. It continued to do
what it had always done, strengthening
its infrastructure, beefing up its
borders, improving its defenses, and
making itself more valuable for the
Continental cost. It shifted political
course committing to restore judicial
independence and resetting relations
with the European Union. Poland's
mission paid off. The EU eventually gave
in unblocking the entire 137 billion
euro package including approximately 60
billion euros in recovery and resilience
facility or RRF funds. It was a complete
capitulation by the EU establishment and
a remarkable victory for Poland. It had
overturned the odds gaming the system to
enjoy an enormous injection of Western
capital all while maintaining a solid
and stable stance of sovereign defiance.
By this point Poland had attained the
very summit of its strategic leverage.
It was strong economically and
militarily and it had beaten the West at
its own game. But while the Warsaw
leaders celebrated they didn't realize
they were losing a battle that couldn't
be fought with tanks or subsidies.
Another long-standing narrative has also
persisted around Poland as the years
have gone by. It claims that the country
is some sort of conservative cultural
fortress, a nation that has effectively
sealed its borders against the
demographic shifts that are occurring
elsewhere across the European continent.
Warsaw's leaders have pushed this myth
repeatedly stating that they will never
adopt the immigration oriented models of
places like Germany and the United
Kingdom. But the data says something
completely different. In 2022 it issued
over 700,000 first residence permits to
non-EU citizens. For six years running
Warsaw has issued more work permits to
non-EU nationals than any other EU
member including Germany and France.
Poland claims to be some sort of bastion
of anti-immigration policy, yet imports
more foreign labor than the countries
its leaders like to criticize. Hundreds
of thousands of workers have been
brought in from all over the globe
including countries like India,
Uzbekistan and the Philippines. Why?
Because it was the only way that Poland
would survive. The country's growth came
at a cost. Eventually, it found itself
with businesses that were on the verge
of booming, but a massive lack of labor
to power them. The country's
unemployment rate had dropped to one of
the lowest levels in Europe, but there
were still too many jobs and not enough
people to fill them. To prevent a
catastrophic economic collapse, the
[music] state flipped its immigration
stance on its head. It funneled hundreds
of thousands of foreign workers into
logistics hubs, manufacturing plants,
and critical industries. It was never a
permanent solution. [music] In fact,
importing labor is merely a stopgap
measure for a much darker, permanent
crisis looming over this trillion-dollar
economy. What Poland really wanted was
to have more homegrown workers to fill
roles and power its continued economic
expansion. There was just one problem.
The country was heading straight for a
dramatic demographic cliff. In 2016,
Warsaw launched the Family 500 Plus
program. It offered a monthly, tax-free
cash benefit of 500 złoty to families,
around $130,
for every child they had. It was an
aggressive measure to encourage Polish
people to have more kids. It was leveled
up in 2024, becoming the 800 Plus
program with a new and improved monthly
payment of 800 złoty, almost $220. The
Polish government went all in. They
hoped this would be enough to reverse
its nation's demographic decline.
>> [music]
>> It wasn't. The pro-family program
certainly helped countless Polish
people, easing child poverty and making
it easier for households to put food on
the table, but it didn't improve the
number of babies being born. By 2023,
Poland's fertility rate had fallen to
1.16 children per woman. The trend
continued in 2024, with the rate
dropping even lower to 1.11. It was the
lowest in all of Europe and the lowest
in Poland since the end of the Second
World War. It's nowhere near the
recognized replacement level rate of 2.1
deemed necessary for any population to
remain stable without having to rely on
immigration. Warsaw learned that money
alone can't solve its demographic
decline. The causes run deeper. They are
structural, shaped by social change in
Poland, and those same changes are tied
to its economic boom. Because as Poland
surged swiftly towards its
trillion-dollar economy, a housing
crisis emerged in the country's big
urban centers. In countries like Warsaw
and Krakow, average property prices
haven't just risen, they have soared.
For a young Polish couple just starting
off, even a simple one-bedroom apartment
feels out of reach. This has forced
millions of people into rental
insecurity or massive mortgages. When
people don't know where they'll be
living next year, or if they can even
make their next mortgage payment,
starting a family is rarely the top
priority. At the very same time, Poland
is also sprinting headfirst into a
deadly environmental trap. The country's
industrial surge was fueled by fossil
fuels. Poland still relies heavily on
coal for around 50% of its electrical
energy. That means it has the most
carbon-intensive power grid in all of
Europe. Poland's reliance on fossil
fuels means a ticking clock is looming
over the country. The EU is pushing
ahead with strict climate [music]
targets that will force member states to
cut emissions quickly. That means Poland
will have to shut down large parts of
its coal infrastructure, setting off a
chain reaction through its economy.
Higher energy prices, a weaker cost
advantage, and a country that may no
longer look as attractive to global
manufacturers. Its exports will suffer
and its revenue streams will be
squeezed. If it dares to defy the EU's
rules, it could face devastating border
tariffs that would undermine its
position inside the single market. In
short, Warsaw is speeding straight into
a brick wall, and it may not have enough
time to slow down before the collision
comes. Even with the challenges ahead,
Poland has succeeded in changing the
face of Europe. The continental map has
been redrawn. The historical
architecture that saw the Western powers
exert control for generations has been
smashed. While the old guard of Paris
and Berlin was busy with bureaucracy and
political polarization, Poland wasn't
just rewriting the rulebook, it was
inventing its own, and in doing so, it
was dragging the continent's center of
gravity to the east. Poland is no longer
an emerging market. It's no longer a
subservient peripheral partner. It's now
the face of 21st century Europe. Warsaw
exploited the EU's financial structures
to build its own world-class
infrastructure. It offered a more
profitable and attractive alternative to
the corporations of the German
Mittelstand. Even when war came to its
doorstep, it made all the right moves to
capitalize on the situation. It's a
heavily armed, highly industrialized
powerhouse, and it reached that point
not by conforming to the classic Western
liberal playbook, but by charting its
own course. And that very course could
be the one that wins the 21st century if
and only if Poland can survive its
ongoing demographic collapse. The
country stands on a precipice. It's
become a European superpower. It has
fortified its borders. It's gained
enormous influence and respect on the
world stage. It has achieved what once
seemed impossible. The only question
left is, can it hold on? Poland's
ambitious moves couldn't come at a more
important moment. As tensions rise
across Europe, every major power is
keeping a close eye on Russia. Watch
what will actually happen if Russia
invades Poland [music] to see how a
Russian advance would play out. Or click
on this video.